et
[Musique]
m
les cours
c'est la foi jeudi
d
m
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
moi
il
hamon
non
pardon s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
bravo bravo
pardon
je peux
la star
tout seul on va voir mais voilà
mais bon
les gens ont froid
[Applaudissements]
en gros
on va
[Applaudissements]
on
tron
auparavant
à
chez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
je suis
pour le foot on a quand même
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît les prendre
l'enjeu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
oh
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
là
enfin tous leurs propositions
[Applaudissements]
on sera ambitieux voyez pas que je suis
occupé à linge
excusez moi non mais des hommes sont
écrits vous voyez des choix bien en
direct ce soir avec commentaires en
direct d'une quote part les dernières
bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur le
jeu
je veux un peu
je ne sais pas
jean
je viens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
non
aucun doute
je vous dis pas
la plateforme
[Musique]
ce n'est pas blanchi
m
[Applaudissements]
je vais
[Musique]
m
pardon et sa patrie des titres
pas bon pas bon
[Musique]
bon pas mon chez moi
je passais pendant ces fêtes
ouais
jamais
ça marche regardez sa section animation
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
rapport de m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon c'est vrai
alors
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi
dans la
[Applaudissements]
on
non
[Applaudissements]
à
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non content
je me rappelle
bon plan
[Applaudissements]
m
g
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
à
[Musique]
on n'en veut pas
à
de l'électro
cliquez là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et là pas du tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
ce que j'ai
à
ouais
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
chez moi
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
quoi
ah ah
non
[Applaudissements]
en temps mais
il en ressort
or
on
oh
[Applaudissements]
m
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
ma peau
[Applaudissements]
à
et
[Musique]
enfin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ans
non
au
matin
alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
oh
et
ouais
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
liberté
mais
écoutez
elle tord
sitôt
le temps
tous ensemble tous ensemble
tous ensemble
[Applaudissements]
toujours en douceur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au
combat
gros combat
paquereau cobas
[Applaudissements]
face aux
pas con ton pas
[Applaudissements]
à
pas trop
pas trop tampa bay
touchez pas aux morts
[Applaudissements]
touché aux mains
touchez pas
[Applaudissements]
position
m
[Applaudissements]
au contraire
à
oh
trop peur
enfin
oh
réaction
[Applaudissements]
proposition
c'est bien
parti
la
compétition
[Applaudissements]
reddition
pas trop richaud
[Applaudissements]
liberté
ah ouais
[Applaudissements]
sa passion de la boue
tha
à
comment
aïe
emma
s
lave en fusion
unissons nos voix
à
[Musique]
vachon
ce que je regarde
sa chaîne
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
bonjour
oh
[Applaudissements]
m
à
et
est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce que vous les autres l'énergie
[Applaudissements]
celle-ci ne résiste au temps enfin ceci
ne
[Applaudissements]
sera pas
pas
non
car
[Applaudissements]
sinon
patino
[Applaudissements]
j'ai hâte
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
m
ja
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j
vers le haut
[Musique]
revers
je vois
j'envoie le chapeau
[Musique]
ce
qu'elle veut
bah
chauffer
[Applaudissements]
et
non
[Applaudissements]
m
nous trouver
avec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
m
[Musique]
à
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
et
et rés
les listes
et
unis blé
unité
éviter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les morts
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis heureux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
copé
[Applaudissements]
et
m
ouais
[Applaudissements]
et
est ce que vous êtes toujours et
rivotril zuckerberg
est ce que vous allez vous laisser
frères prévenus et makro
[Applaudissements]
vous allez laisser ces fous divisez
votre pays et vous fanny
alors nous restons unis en lutte on se
crée de nombreux intervenants
comprendre la parole en attendant
trompera vaut d'être là aussi noël
musique
non
[Musique]
belle utopie you soon
en raison des murs de masques qui de
crachin raison
[Musique]
la moisson qui que
rien
en dessous des places
[Musique]
lee
obama
oui
c'est bien
jouer
[Musique]
oh
pas lui
est ce de la caisse
[Musique]
toujours
grand
non messieurs
social
je vous
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
re bonjour bonjour à tous
écoutez vous êtes on est
extraordinairement nombreux on va
commencer avant tout on arrive à ceci on
pourra pas on pourra pas compenser on va
devoir attendre longtemps mais sachez
que encore des gens qui sont quasiment
au début de la manifestation
nous avons beaucoup plus de monde que le
17 juillet
le pays s'est lié
à cros le fou chez spie
apprend le psychopathe c'est fini
aux revenus élevés
alors je retourne le voir venir nous
allons commencer les interventions ici
sur l'écran pour nous battre pour
résister et de liberté liberté liberté
universelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous n'avons jamais été aussi nombreux
et les messieurs nous vivons un moment
historique dans cette résistance
veille alger messieurs aujourd'hui nous
faisons l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
dans les années qui viennent les coûts
passant toujours difficile tout risque
aux soins de perdre du terrain bg latter
conditions que nous en gagnerons
écoles et libertés seront restaurés en
france
nous sommes un pays de tradition
résistante et nous entendons bien
perpétuer cette noble tradition
resistor spray distance
réduite aux
résistances
nous allons commencer
par le week end rapport l'éclat
néo-parisien du patriote au public
bourse commence
le rituel du rampeù comme d'habitude
mais des dizaines de milliers bravo
deux buts pour la préfecture de police
de paris c'est pas grave nous allons
faire comme d'habitude au rituel du
drapeau et chanté la marseillaise car
nous avons toujours douze 12 août où
nous parlons bravo à vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allons enfants de la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
on est
le haut
[Musique]
euros
et
en
eo
à
[Musique]
non
or
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à vous bonne année 2022 la résistance à
la lutte acharnée bravo à vous et tenu à
associer un peu deux fois l'an 2000 et
je sens que vous avez décrété la levée
en masse
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes réunis ici par rapport à une
union sacrée qui va qui courent le point
carré à paul reynaud union sacrée contre
l'ennemi extérieur
aujourd'hui nos sacrée contre l'ennemi
intérieur pas kronis cofidis européisme
en galice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez répondu à l'appel de florian
philippot en master d'ul ont sacré c'est
comme en matière d'amour y'a pas en soi
de l'amour du nom sacré il ya des
preuves d'amour et les profs d'union
sacrée et si florian philippot légitimer
affaire c'est qu'il a appelé le 12
juillet 2020 au rassemblement puis à
partir du 24 octobre 2021 nous sommes
autour de lui réuni les patriotes et
nous avons toutes les semaines manifesté
place pierre laroque la légitimité c'est
ça et dans le combat on n'est pas
ailleurs et n'est pas dans le vert mais
dans les mots il faut combattre il faut
se pincer en crépon
concrètement à ce qui nous attend pas un
cofidis ou de folie et freiner
cette levée en masse devant la
poursuivre non et nous ne vont
structurer cette union sacrée pour
qu'elle perdure dans le temps et que
nous donnions de plus en plus de preuves
que celui qui veut nous emmerder qui
alerte les clochettes armes dont
regardons l'arbre nous lui laissons la
clochette et nous gardons là
résistons
résistons résistons résistons
[Musique]
la résistance et mondiale est dense et
plus mondial nous savons que nos
adversaires s'assainir doux si tout ceci
dit et 2 avant l'immense honneur d'avoir
sur cet écran vidéo
le représentant qu'un lieu de la liberté
qui on livre des manifestations
canadienne pour la liberté
il dirige le parti populaire du canada
nous pouvons applaudir et être très
honorée d'écouter et de regarder maxime
bernier
bonjour chers patriotes cousins français
gaspard la grande manifestation
nationale de ligne on s'écrit et un
merci à mon ami florian philippot de
m'avoir invité la bataille pour la
liberté rejoint tous les peuples ici au
canada tout comme vous présentement en
france au moment même où vous regardez
cette vidéo je serai à montréal pour
manifester contre les mesures
liberticides comme l'imposent les
citoyens et de nos deux pays vivent
textuellement des moments très
difficiles
nous leaders prennent constamment vos
droits et libertés c'est inacceptable et
appelé vous le président a dit qu'il
fera tout pour emmerder et non respect
et mon premier ministre de son côté
andré télé non vaccinés de misogyne et
de résister il veut tout faire pour moi
la vie plus divisés en prônant la
discrimination et la ségrégation
pour il ya de bons citoyens et de
mauvais citoyens nous nous n'avons qu'un
non pas diviser mais unis unir tous les
citoyens sous la pluie de la liberté les
dresser peu fondateur du parti populaire
du canada sont la liberté la
responsabilité
lick it et il respire le mouvement
grandit de jour en jour à la première
élection en 2009 nous avons obtenu 1,6
pour cent du vote national et à la
dernière élection en octobre dernier
nous avons fait 5 pour ça et aujourd'hui
nous sommes environ à 10 % dans les
sondages
le message porte malgré le fait comme
fait taire et sans suivre nous sommes le
seul parti politique au canada qui
rejette l'hystérie collier et sa
tyrannie médical tout comme vous nous
disons non au prince pentax mal non au
couvre-feu non au contrat et non toutes
ces mesures
elle est juste et inconstitutionnelle ce
n'est pas en tapant âme aux droits et
libertés que nous allons vaincre la
pandémie le virus pas toujours existé
mais il faudra vivre avec ce virus et
respecter les choix de chacun tout en
protégeant les plus vulnérables nous
faisons le même qu'en bas saut
différents continents quand dumont le
combat pour la liberté
car la liberté finira toujours par
triompher
line été
liberté
ils étaient
merci merci à maxime bernier d'avoir
fait ce message de ce merdier nous
sommes très heureux très honoré de
savoir que nous avons des canadiens
livre a le côté
nous avons parmi nous un jalil et
étudiants ils représentent la cocarde
cette étudiante qui s'est illustré par
sa défense des libertés depuis le début
de cette crise démocratique
je vous prie d'écouté et d'aboutir jade
et qu'on est chère pour la coca
étudiante
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous je m'appelle jade et je
suis membre de la cocarde étudiante et
j'aimerais aujourd'hui m'adresser
particulièrement aux étudiants qui n'ont
pas été épargnés par les mesures
liberticides
nous avons passé la nuit dernière entre
continents fermeture des universités
mais aussi des lieux de sociabilité tels
que les bars la précarité étudiante à
gloser et décrochage scolaire se sont
accumulés mais aussi parfois les
dépressions et le sentiment de solitude
nous avons tous sacrifié une partie de
notre jeunesse
mais la situation actuelle est plus
grave qu'il existe un désormais deux
catégories d'étudiants
les étudiants en vacciner qui peuvent
rentrer chez leurs parents et ce qui ne
l'est les étudiants vacciner
[Applaudissements]
les étudiants vaccine équipes installées
dans les lieux de sociabilité et ceux
qui ne veulent pas
et dans certaines universités les
étudiants va signer qui peuvent passer
leurs partiels en présentiel et ceux qui
sont censés aller passer consiste en
ciel
[Applaudissements]
si la situation demeure ainsi c'est bien
parce que trop de jeunes refusent de
prendre leur avenir en main
c'est vrai qu'il est plus facile
tactique et ses libertés que de défendre
d'affirmer que ce n'est rien que le
présenter un pass pour prendre le train
ou pour aller au cinéma ça serait même
le prix de la liberté un tocard
d'étudiantes nous refusons cette
conception dévoyée de la liberté
[Applaudissements]
nous refusons ce money d'une société de
surveillance mâle fun
nous avons long toute la jeunesse qui
refusent ces restrictions qui refusent
cette soumission à nous rejoindre à
manifester à nos côtés pour défendre
notre dignité et notre avis dire
libertaire est ni la fosse
12 ans
au
prince
[Applaudissements]
nous avons un autre message vidéo
d'un homme qui n'est pas là actuellement
qui est des taux auprès des siens
il s'agit de marc toyer qui vit tragédie
qui est l'époux de mauricette qui est un
message poignant à vous adresser qui
vous a envoyé pour vous le faire écouter
parfois tendancieux
bonjour je vous fais remarquer loyer
je vous parle le fichier mois
d'enlisement qui est transformée
aujourd'hui en chambre d'hôpital vous
voyez je suis dans mon salon l'homme on
faisait des défaites en famille
je suis au chevet de mon épouse ma
recette qui a élevé de graves effets
secondaires suite à l'action pfizer ça
fait maintenant quatre mois qu'elle est
enfermée dans son corps ouvrez les yeux
elle me regarde pas secourir mais
derrière moi il ya des perfusions elle
est alimenté et hydraté comme ça et je
me suis enfermé avec elle dans la maison
depuis maintenant quatre mois je
pourrais appeler à sortir de mon jardin
tellement la prise en charge et vaud
c'est une maladie extrêmement rare on
parle de la maladie lacoste jacob c'est
une maladie qui est apparu comme on
risque dans le rapport de la loi sur le
médicament kaiser jeu que je vais pas
vous appelez ça un médecin et donc il ya
des cas on va tout seul non
mon coin dans l'oise j'ai après avoir
témoigné sur une chaîne de télévision
reçu vingt témoignages similaires dont
19 tous survenus après vaccination
freezer j'ai interpellé fera public d'un
document pendant des semaines et des
semaines
en disant que
il y à un danger grave avec cette
pathologie qui est extrêmement bien que
cinq cas sur un million que dans des
temps plus anciens avec des responsables
politiques plus responsable on avait par
exemple arrêter toute la filière viande
puisqu'on retrouvait cette maladie
la fondation farines animales
aujourd'hui ça semble gêner personne
j'ai compris que visiblement les actifs
qui se comporte de multiples machines de
guerre dirigeant s'est considérablement
l'intérêt mondial doit imaginer dans ma
femme je fais partie de la chair à canon
comme on en voyait sur le terrain dans
les anciens
écoutez je reste serein parce que
maintenant mon quotidien la wii et je
le tiens d'un mort et 7 et je fais ça à
moins de journée
pour essayer de la compagnie au maximum
voilà alors je voudrais que ce
témoignage servent que les pouvoirs
publics prennent enfin conscience il va
les élections présidentielles j'espère
que d'autres politiques
com
florian philippot auront courage de
parler de tout ça parce que là je parle
vraiment proche
voilà moi je les engagements pour
personne mais je veux remercier
aujourd'hui florent clio parce que il
est un des rares à avoir eu ce courage
donc
ça amérique nous de le préciser j'espère
que ça va que d'autres vont lui emboîter
pas voilà je vous souhaite à tous une
très bonne journée et surtout va rester
mobilisés parce que on a vraiment besoin
de créer effectivement une union
certains parlent du nom ça fait je pense
que c'est une excellente idée voilà
merci à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo bravo pour ce message de courage
de monsieur noyés
[Musique]
d'eau
nous avons un soutien total
un soutien total pour son combat un
soutien total pour son message message
de courage message combatif et messages
dont nous honorons d'en être les
destinataires
aujourd'hui celui janvier 2022 années de
l'art du début de la tyrannie sanitaire
+2
nous sommes là pour cette union sacrée
tous ensemble il y a des représentants
de divers mouvements politiques
d'associations et gens du monde de la
culture et citoyens des médecins des
pompiers et tant d'autres dans la vie de
tous les jours avant sa tyrannie nous
pouvions avoir des choses qui nous
différencier sur tout un tas de sujets
et c'est pas grave c'est ça la
démocratie et sur un sujet aussi central
que la survie des principes de la france
que la survie de nos libertés
que le maintien d' le maintien même de
notre citoyenneté y est ô combien utile
précieux et même indispensable d'être
tous unis
merci d'être là
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes là et nous accueillons un
souverainiste comme il y aura beaucoup
parmi vous un souverainiste de redon il
est également essayiste et il s'est
illustré
dans des temps un ardent combattant de
la liberté
ces derniers mois et même depuis plus
longtemps encore je vous prie
t'applaudir paul marie coûteaux
[Applaudissements]
mes chers
compatriotes
nous n'avons qu'une chose a demandé il
faut le demander à nous mêmes les uns
aux autres et meubles exigé
nous avons à nous demander les uns les
autres d'être toujours plus et toujours
de français c'est à dire qu'est ce
qu'être français
c'est à dire de réfléchir
c'est à dire de comprendre le monde
c'est-à-dire de saisir l'histoire
et de ces tirs les grands mouvements du
monde et de les relier les uns les
autres c'est à dire le travail
consistant à relier les choses les unes
aux autres êtres intelligents
nous avons un immense du français c'est
la vieille ancestrale
millénaire
intelligence française
ce que nous avons à faire d'abord il a
demandé aux uns et aux autres c'est à
comprendre ce dont nous sommes les
témoins sans toujours comprendre car il
est difficile d'être contemporain dans
sa propre histoire ce qui nous arrive
est bien en réfléchissant mes chers
compatriotes
on découvre assez vite qu'eux aussi
brutale soit il
l'épisode kiko vide n'est qu'un épisode
n'est qu'une étape
dans la longue terry fils du pouvoir à
l'échelle de la planète par une poignée
d'oligarchie mondiale coalisés
ça a commencé depuis des années et des
années je ne mentionne que pour mémoire
la terrible affaire du référendum de
jce fait au peuple
qui n'a vu qu'à comprendre d'autres
choses
c'est à dire plutôt lui est imposé et
qui doit suivre l'europe lui est imposé
contre son gré une grande partie de ce
qu'on appelle progrès lui est imposé
contre son gré c'est un totalitarisme
pur et parfait
qui s'installe
partout dans le monde et spécialement en
europe aussi dur aussi terrible que
d'autres totalitarisme que nous avons
combattu et on vous fait toujours
victorieux
ce totalitarisme à une idéologie je le
disais le progressisme depuis des
siècles le progressisme a pris
possession du monde avec ses illusions
et l'illusion cyprès qui consiste à
changer l'homme contre son gré
c'est l'ouverture de tous les
totalitarismes
le communisme soviétique le communiste
chinois le nazisme et autres
progressisme je dis bien progressé oui
qui maintenant est allié avec une
immense
masse
qui est aussi en train de faire
l'histoire contre nous c'est la massive
société technicienne la logique
technicienne et bien la liaison du
progressisme d'un logiciel est
extrêmement difficile à déjouer il faut
que nous la protection les autres autre
et il faut que nous parvenions à opposer
le seul socle de toutes les résistances
c'est à dire les peuples du monde est à
bord le peuple français
oui avec nos traditions nos valeurs la
conscience de nos siècle de liberté
notre lampe à propos de la vente
d'ailleurs leur parenthèse pour vous
demander de ne plus jamais parler de
vaccins nous n'avons pas à faire un
vaccin vers des injections geniki
expérimental de père dont j'avais ne
perdant jamais la bataille des veaux si
vous perdu la bataille des mots nous
sommes perdu notre meilleur rempart
c'est la langue française et son
exactitude
si nous remportons cette bataille
si la france donne l'exemple au monde un
pays qui reste libre comme il l'a fait
depuis des siècles et des siècles nous
sommes sûrs de vaincre sinon réunissons
le peuple et je crois qu'un jour je vais
faire cette suggestion à mon vieil ami
et filippo il faudra que nous l'ayons
les luttes que nous organisions temps le
printemps une grande journée du collège
française pour lier les colère du peuple
les yeux aux autres
[Musique]
c'est à dire que si nous pour finir si
nous arrivons à mobiliser les le peuple
français nous sommes sûrs de vaincre car
la france dans sa longue histoire a
toujours vécu et par elle pour et rompt
et fuit merci beaucoup merci à paul
marie coûteaux essayiste souverainiste
et soutien d'eric zemmour qui nous fait
le plaisir est avec nous
[Applaudissements]
nous avons par vide ou
un représentant du collectif est pendue
qui s'est illustré ces derniers mois il
s'agit de christophe chinois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous
je suis d'abord venu remercier florian
philippot de savoir éviter parce que 120
ce qui vous
mais bon c'est à dire qu'ils sont un feu
qui organise les élections
je suis venu vous dire aussi que
beaucoup
beaucoup de mes collègues restaurateurs
commerçants artisans auto-entrepreneurs
libéraux suffisent évidemment de plein
fouet les conséquences des mesures
politiques et m'ont demandé pour ceux
qui n'ont pas pu se déplacer de vous
remercier d'être là pour qui les
subissent et aussi
car nous sommes tous les victimes de
cette politique et je revis de cette
occasion pour vérité et confirmé que non
nous n'avons pas été conviés par les
aides non pour ce qu'ils étaient
éligibles
nous avons perçu une indemnisation très
partielle des pertes et conséquences
globales que nous avons subi six partiel
que certains sont déjà restés sur le
carreau
si partiel que nous allons constater à
partir de ce premier trimestre un départ
d'avalanche 2 déboule bilan calmes
malgré les promesses du ministre le
maire nos activités déjà bien on était
né peut freiner voire stopper depuis
l'instauration du pass politiques et les
dispositions soutient qu'il a annoncé
cette semaine ne sont que de l'enfumage
nous savons
nous savons il l'aurait roué que ce pass
n'avait aucune vertu sanitaire
évidemment
avec leurs mensonges permanents ils ont
accusé tromper toute la population y
compris mes collègues qui ont encore
trop dans le dernier effort
bien sûr au début de cette crise nous
allons tout accepter comme vous comme
tout le monde mais très vite nous avons
courir et dans ce collectif avait alerté
depuis de longs mois qu'ils nous
utilisait déjà comme responsable et
coupable
les grands médias nous ont ignorés
référent exposer les témoins désignent
et de la bien pensante
nous représentants professionnels
représentant nos syndicats nos
fédérations sont restés muets et les
complices tant et si bien oui il tentait
civile que nos animaux sont restés
confidentiels et que depuis le te
foutent et l'impasse politique
ils nous ont carrément clients montage
nous ont obligés à en crever le bien ils
nous ont obligés sous peine d'amendé de
fermeture à être l'esthétique de la
politique sanitaire
d'obligations
un signal d' aiguiser
nos syndicats se sont révélés c'est pour
cette raison que nous venons de créer
notre propre culture syndicale
officielle et légitime
pour tous ceux qui ont compris qu'ils ne
sont que leurs jouets et qu'ils doivent
sortir du jour ne serait ce que par
instinct de survie menons pour tous ceux
qui ont compris que si on les laisse
encore faire son cirque sera sans fin et
que dans l'urgence mais aussi pour
l'avenir il est nécessaire de reus
tribus et les cartes de la
représentation professionnelle
ce syndicat s'appelle antigone et
j'aimerais parce que nous avons encore
du mal à pénétrer la sphère médiatique
je tiens d'ailleurs ici à remercier les
médias alternatifs comme bocce bas les
masques de radio courtoisie gérard qui
nous qui nous donne la parole rt france
j'étais donc que vous portiez cette
information vers ce vous connaissez qui
pourraient être concernés qu'ils soient
commerçants restaurateurs discothèque
artisans auto-entrepreneurs libéraux qui
souffrent également énormément ils
causeront touche pas à propos sur
l'autre ghosn france.com et peuvent
aussi avoir des précisions sur notre
page de notre collectif né pendule c'est
important que l'information circule au
delà des réseaux sociaux c'est
primordial c'est important que la vérité
circulent au delà des eaux sociaux nous
en sommes tous au moins nous les
victoires et ce travail de fourmi finira
par aboutir la solidarité n'est pas un
délit c'est une vertu et si la vérité
quand souvent l'escalier à la fin est
rigolo
je vous remercie donc vraiment de faire
circuler l'information je vais libérer
le micro je voudrais dire à monsieur
attal que non ce ne sont pas ceux qui
s'opposent aux vaccins qui leur merde
les commerçants les restaurateurs c'est
vous c'est l'autre lâcheté et si vous
monsieur kita monte et discriminante
et nous le chemin tron vous n'allez pas
enfermer d'y faire taire les millions
que nous sommes et les millions
supplémentaires que nous serons bientôt
avoir choisi le pc en europe et à titre
personnel je suis fière de vous emmerder
entre ferrand rester dans le groupe
contrôle de l'expérimentation
je suggère de vous nos amis en pilier
jean l'humanité naturel directive est
sèche et surtout surtout que nous ne
lâcherons jamais jamais rien
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes là
quand on insulte le peuple en france
saint ce pays toujours content ça se
paye cash
nous avons promis nous en vidéo un homme
de courage un deuxième soutien d'eric
zemmour qui est avec en vidéo
il s'agit du président du parti via la
voix du peuple
geoffrey les oiseaux
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs chers manifesto
bonjour je regrette de ne pouvoir
participer avec vous à cette
manifestation de ce samedi 8 janvier
mais je tenais à m'adresser à vous
parliez cette vidéo et j'espère que vous
serez nombreux à participer à cet
événement important qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui
je veux d'abord vous adresser à tous et
à toutes les meilleures villes de galles
ils veulent les prospères années de 22
qui sera peut-être plus que les autres
une année de résistance et de combat
je vous également adressé des
remerciements très chaleureux influences
nippone ces équipes ou mouvement des
patriotes pour avoir constamment et
vertueusement organisé donc c'est samedi
ces manifestations de protestation
contre la politique ça l'univers du
gouvernement qui nourrit encore
aujourd'hui et je vous remercie pour ses
doutes de votre attachement à la liberté
puisque c'est sa cour est venu samedi à
ferries il apparaît non je vais
effectivement départ la question
sanitaire si la question de liberté
c'est la question de nos libertés
fondamentales
c'est notre volonté de remettre en cause
la stratégie vaccinale gouvernementale
qui méprisent nos libertés et aux droits
et dina meyer par notre santé
depuis longtemps de descendance et
libertés dans la diversité de ses
expressions la liberté des français qui
veut être décidée parce que je considère
que c'est un choix personnel qui qui est
l'effet de la volonté et qui pourtant
sont pris pour des imbéciles et on a
trouvé depuis la liberté des français
qui ne veulent pas être vaccinés parce
que il ne croit pas dans le bénéfice de
ces injections à caractère expérimental
que le gouvernement veut nous faire
subir à toutry la liberté de ceux qui
seront vaccinés parce qu'elles sont
contraints et que cela menace d'être
privés de leur emploi ou de la
profession ils ont dû malheureusement
suivre les injonctions de nuire non la
liberté les médecins qui veulent presser
dès qu'ils sont les premiers à savoir
qui elle est très possible de précoce
contre lacko vide et qui s'entraîne à
engager une inconscience et nos
responsabilités le médecin consolier ce
qui serait affectée par la relance ce
virus est qu'il ya quelques jours vous
le savez à la commission des lois devant
la commission de votre assemblée
nationale le ministre rivayrand a dit
qu'il y avait trois catégories de
personnes qui faire vacciner trois
galeries de nous bassiner je ne reprends
pas cette nomenclature qu'il était à peu
près j'ai dit qu il a oublié l'une
catégorie 16 des français qui ne croient
pas en la parole union qui ne croient
pas dans ses contradictions qui sont
exaspérés par ces incohérences par son
impréparation et par son amateurisme et
par de suture par dessus tout pardon par
ces injures et par son des prix nous
sommes assez grand nombre de français à
être dans cette 4e catégorie et de
manière très étonnante au son le
gouvernement afin de décider et cette
semaine les chercher mais nous avons
franchi une étape supplémentaire
une double étape supplémentaire le pass
vaccinale d'abord a été adoptée à
l'assemblée nationale à mon grand regret
et je pense que nos parlements de ces
drames grandi dans l'adoption de ce
texte
et puis surtout nous avons compté des
intentions qu'on ferme du président de
l'apli qui met ses amis aient décidé de
nous en avons bien choses à dire au
président de la république son événement
de qui sait très bien que si encore le
trio la république se contenter de nous
emmerder cela vous avez à peu près parce
que franchement musiciens habitue depuis
cinq ans et nous avons résisté à tenter
temps de saisie vraie scène c'est le
délire que finalement c'est un autre
équipe de plus et ça c'est pas si grave
que ça mais ce propos est tellement
révélateur de la violence la violence
qu'il assemble gouvernementale ne plus
partager par la boutique
qu'effectivement
cette déclaration de cette semaine quand
une tournure plus inquiétante est au
fond je veux dire au président par la
public
vous permet de vous associer à cette
remarque
le président de la république perd 1,7
note paiera la note de ces injures après
le drapeau européen sous l'arc de
triomphe et la légion d'honneur accordée
à lann à bruz sans ses successeurs ça ne
peut pas rester sans réponse qu'on peut
pas rester sans débit et je vous invite
à faire en sorte que messi l'histoire
sera puni cette protéine et de mâcon
mais il n'en a rien à faire de
l'histoire ça n'a pas d'importance pour
lui c'est sûr dans rouge doivent le lui
faire payer et c'est pourquoi je vous
avais tous mondiale nos différences de
sensibilité ou d'attachement politique à
choisir pour un temps prochain les
personnes qui seront capables de
descendre de liberté et par les gens qui
continueront à lire à l'hôtel et ses
ventes à 1 12 merci votre présence bon
courage nous sommes allés
[Applaudissements]
merci merci à jean frédéric poisson qui
a toujours été là au sort de ce qui
deviendrait l'union sacrée nous avons vu
plusieurs fois aux manifestations sous
l'influencé qu'il ment ça a été l'un des
premiers on peut le produire très fort
[Applaudissements]
cette union sacrée
se fait au travers de différents
courants politiques mais également avec
les artistes puisque nous avons une
flopée d'artistes résistant avec tous
il refuse de se taire et refuse d'avoir
peur il refuse de se laisser faire et
plusieurs d'entre vous prendra pas nous
avons notamment la chance ailleurs
accueillir quelqu'un qui est venu
plusieurs fois manifestation et qui va
enfin prendre la parole il est auteur
comédien vous l'avez connu notamment sur
canal au niveau niveau du programme
action discrète il est courageux il se
bat pour les artistes je vous prie de
faire un tollé en plus fort pour thomas
s'il fit
merci bonjour à vous coûte bonjour corse
est sans doute en train de vous le
demander en voyant saisir ce micro c'est
qui celui là autant sa moustache me dit
vaguement quelque chose autant l'homme
derrière je ne sais pas bien c'est
précisément pour cette raison que
solennellement je tenais à vous
présenter mes excuses
pardon pardon de ne pas être dany boon
ni jean paul rouve j'aurais tellement
aimé me présenter devant vous sinon avec
le statut de star du point avec celui de
vedette d'artistes qui compte pour
pouvoir me faire le relais de
l'injustice que vous vivez que nous
et d'en porter dans le sillage de mes
paroles les voix inaudible que milliers
anodine et odieux ça eh bien vous avez
qui devant vous un moustachu de
troisième ce qui a bien peu de chances
de renverser le cours des événements ni
de faire trembler la république est bien
qu importe vous l'aurez compris j'ai un
peu haute oui un peu honte de faire
partie de cette prétendue grandes
familles du spectacle qui subit de plein
fouet une terrible épidémie une épidémie
d'extinction de voix alors oui j'en veux
aux artistes oui j'en aux artistes et à
ceux qui ont un nom aux artistes qui ont
une carrière derrière eux qui n'ont plus
rien à prouver
pas parce que je considère l'artiste
comme un citoyen supérieur non mais
parce que l'art est l'artiste s'adresse
au coeur des gens qui laboure ou qui
travaillent les émotions de l'âme parce
qu'il sait ou plutôt ils devraient
savoir écouter et comprendre les maux de
la société pour les retranscrire en
chanson en filmant l'oeuvre littéraire
en peinture en photographie ou autre
mais sinon l'artiste s'il n'est pas ça
il est quoi
s'il ne se fait pas l'écho de la douleur
et de l'injustice qu'ils soient
humoristes ou dramaturge racines que
j'appelle même combat il sert à quoi
c'est donc bien légitime de se demander
où sont passés tous nos artistes et lé
ga les copains
toutes et tous
joe si vous avez pleuré comme je lé fais
ce soir là devant mes enfants à écouter
le premier ministre duclos rieuse nation
accusé sa propre fille de 11 ans de
l'avoir contaminée
étant les justiciers sa politique de
généralisation massive à nos enfants
mais
[Applaudissements]
tu lui as canet marion cotillard il vous
reste encore quelques quelques mouchoirs
vos yeux ne sont pas devenus totalement
sec c'est que l'arbre et d'empathie
stromae t ou jean dujardin
tu aurais quand même pas passer trop de
soirées interlope au coin de est devenu
sourd aux cris d aides soignants des
médecins des militaires des policiers
sensés de porter atteinte alors volonté
fondamental à leur intégrité sous peine
d'être licenciés de se retrouver à la
rue de courir le risque de se voir
retirer la garde de leurs enfants
cad
kad merad alors c'est vrai et oublier
les codes que civil article 16 la loi
interdit toute atteinte à la dignité de
la personne chacun a droit au respect de
son corps le corps humain est inviolable
[Applaudissements]
romain duris d'air india lorsque vous
irez chercher vos césar avant de monter
sur scène vous montrerez votre pass
sanitaire origine ou pompier de service
au bas des escaliers et puis bientôt
accepter sans broncher que le monde
pour toutes occasions ta vie
olivier py philippe caubère isabelle
huppert vincent macaigne emmanuelle
béart jacques weber ne le dites pas que
vous n'avez pas pleurer se touchent
juillet lorsque le président de la
république d'un respectable pays a
exposé sa conception du progrès
et qui récidive le 5 janvier
en affirmant tout naturellement qu'une
partie des citoyens mieux sous des
citoyens
[Musique]
c
après cela vous aurez encore sauvés et
abaisse antigone déclamant des vers qui
prône y inviter il a juste plus quand on
interdit importateurs et accès au
théâtre au motif qu'il n'aurait pas reçu
30 microgrammes d'une injection dans
leur corps
noir ont terrifié le spectacle de vison
si vous tous vous faites le vent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fabrice luchini faux dit tu es vécu en
compagnie de jean de la fontaine depuis
30 ans pour finir le col de l'est par le
collier de melesse idéologique comme les
chiens apprivoiser de la fable
michel fugain pierre richard et michel
jacques dutronc vous n'avez pas fait
tout ce chemin pour vous arrêter aux
derniers combats luc besson le dernier
combat c'est pas celui là
la vie qui nous a dit la musique ne fait
pas rire les dictateurs soit mes photos
même qu'elle soit accompagnée de paroles
cette musique un parti qui pour les
porter ses paroles vincent lindon
sandrine kiberlain interdite de 9
lorsque vous ne voyez défiler souvent
sonné tout de 6e arrondissement pourquoi
vous descendez pas avec nous
tirez les rideaux
dont tu te ra jamais la réalité de ce
qui se fait au prix mais
[Musique]
seriez peut-être peur
peur de quoi je ne sais pas mais at il
dit si bien sur des ouï corps de vous
afficher dans un cortège de complotiste
c'est peut-être pire tenons à signer
c'est ça on ainsi françois cluzet
se sont re et nouveau intouchable les
non vaccinés
tortel fréquentable dirigé de surcroît
par un meneur d'extrême droite l'invs s
est dite disqualifié or aux revenus je
vous demande de vous taire et j'en
profite pour passer un monsieur s'il
vaut pour remercier
au lit de m'offrir une tribune parce que
nous sommes et jamais parlé de notre vie
est bien votre combativité sans relâche
vous avez forcément respect et celui de
bien d'autres alors pas des artistes non
mais je me permets toutefois monsieur
philibeaux de nous mettre en garde ce
n'est certainement pas en manifestant
tous les samedis depuis plus d'un an en
cherchant à éliminer les discriminations
et les divisions entre français à
écouter inlassablement leurs souffrances
ni en vous mobilisant pour obtenir la
vérité que vous allez devenir fasciste
at-il auprès des nobles l'ignoble dessin
une fois arrivé au pouvoir de vouloir
supprimer et qui berthet et surveiller
le peuple copine et les minorités comme
tout bon dictateur qui se respecte non
il ya encore du boulot à faire monsieur
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est tellement plus simple que se
blottir dans la chaleur d'opinion
commandées bien lové au milieu de la
chorale de la pensée dominante alors
qu'est ce qui s'est passé florent pagny
ça y est ils ont eu pour de bon des
libertés de france et
gérard jugnot
thierry lhermitte christian clavier le
pacte d'actionnaires ce serait la
liberté mais laquelle celle de pouvoir
aller bronzer au soleil pourtant on est
tous d'accord bilan n'est plus d'accord
les enfants c'est notre trésor c'est
notre trésor les justifier dans les
films ils sont là pour protéger les
enfants pas les milliardaires de
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
[Applaudissements]
je ne comprends pas toutes ces histoires
douces et volent texte toutes ces
chansons toutes ces leçons de lycée pour
de faux alain delon insoumis monsieur
klein c'est juste une histoire gérard
depardieu colonel chabert uranus
germinal
c'est plus que du simple si les benjamin
biolay y restera quoi donc on et
laitages il n'y aurait donc rien
derrière tout ça un rien au fond des
oeuvres la morale de l'histoire ce
quelque chose qui nous dépasse et qui
nous relie au vrai au juste tout ça
c'est de la fiction
bientôt la liberté la dignité l'humanité
ce ne sont pas que des slogans vides
scandé le samedi par une poignée de
connard jolie star c'est une esonet de
temps en temps alors discuté avec ses
gens ses colères tu verrais qu'on y
trouve que la bonté de l'humanisme de la
solidarité de la terre faisant toutes
ces notions pour lesquels on s'est battu
depuis des décennies alors je préfère by
john raccourcir mais les copains veulent
et venez manifester vous allez voir
d'ici cinq ans on chante
dernière chose derrière chaussée puis
l'expérience pour eux tous les comédiens
les comédiennes vous prenez vos enfants
avec vous
face à un miroir
vous les regardez
et vous prenez votre poubelle fouet vous
leur
vous saviez les amours
[Musique]
il est dans le camp des vainqueurs est
dans le camp des gentils et du bon côté
celui où l'on a foot ou s'il ya de moins
les yeux au monde la dignité la
tolérance la vérité ces vielles inepties
la folk et des portes son talent qu il
va jouer aux apprentis sorciers
maintenant avec vous parce que la bonne
santé gratuite naturel ça n'existe pas
pour être en bonne santé il n'y a qu'un
moyen de faire piquer toute ta vie et
franchement si vous y arrivez c'est
qu'ils aient vraiment des bons kobe
intérêts des vrais bons comédiens
chapeau par des artistes
[Applaudissements]
bravo au quilit serre ges les personnes
qui doivent récupérer les sacs de kate
après tommy qu'ils aillent sur le côté
droit de la scène quand on est face à la
scène nous avons d'autres aux artistes
courageux qu'on peut applaudir
aujourd'hui et notamment quelqu'un qui
nous avons déjà eu l'honneur d'avoir à
l'effet station et s'éveille s'appelle
albert kassa be et la plupart d'entre
vous le connaissent mieux sous le nom de
ppr des forbans
bonjour les amis d'abord je salue votre
courage malgré la pluie les intempéries
je vais faire très court parce que je
vais 1er florian
je lis attroupement les alliés ce que
vous nous rappeler de ce gamin qui était
présent lors des prestations de notre
show man de président ce mot me l'avait
interpellé en l'appelant et manu alors
le concerné avait trouvé cela grossier
et dévergondée et il avait réprimandé le
gamin en lui disant qu'il était mal
élevé que doit penser ce que l'on veut
et irrévérencieux aujourd'hui de la
sortie de notre manu de ces derniers
jours qui nous on est un peu il doit
probablement trouvé que ce monde est
vachement injuste voilà
la réaction
ressiot qu'on n'a pas arrêté devant
la russie au cola plus bas
en entendant cette cette sortie
grossière et maintenant les lui qu'on
aurait préféré une son père et châtillon
son langage a été de dire en purée au
pardon il fallait mettre les
français à dos puisqu'il dit vouloir les
emmerder
mais croyez moi la technique est tout
autre le piège est tendu est aussi
visible mais dieu connaît au milieu d'un
visage voyez plutôt la france est
responsable de tout le tissu de l'europe
sur le soldat inconnu plutôt que le
soldat plutôt que le drapeau français
[Musique]
et oui et légion d'honneur qu'on
distribue l envie est maintenant une
sainte acte de saartjie à la plaza
langage chartier tout ceci est réfléchie
et outils c'est une stratégie mine de
rien pour nous endormir et pour nous
faire passer ce pass thaksin al se passe
vaccinale est la plus grosse des
hérésies de tout ce que j'ai vécu et de
tout ce que l'humanité a vécu
nous prendre nos libertés au fur et à
mesure de notre vie ils ont adoré duty
comme si nous étions des enfants comme
si nous sommes des enfants rappelez-vous
aujourd'hui il est interdit de grandes
et un enfant il est interdit de donner
la fessée à l'enfant en revanche il est
tout à fait autorisé de nous dire à
quelle aune de m'en sortir akena de vous
créer ce que doom ou quoi ne mangez les
amis pour me par fax idée vacciner
faites ce que vous voulez c'est pas à
eux de nous dire que ce vaccin est un
vaccin puisque en réalité il est
administré avec tellement de touche qui
ne ressent plus un médicament qu'un
médecin voilà manille il s'appelle pas
lui ne s'appelle pas autrement manu est
tout seul et il peut nous emmerder ines
c'est incroyable et nous ne sommes
nombreux et nous ne pouvons pas
l'emmerder
dommage alors je vous en prie des amis
arrêtez de vous faire la guerre entre
vous arrêter vous détestez et faites ce
que vous voulez en gros je vous fais des
bisous et peut-être qu'un jour les
artistes pourront remonter sur scène
sereinement salut les amis merci estimé
shekhar à vis à vis décidés mais
lorsque les concerts propos je pense
qu'on peut dire est ce qu'on doit le
voir
on sera tous là je vous demande s'il
vous plaît il ya encore des personnes
qui a continué à arriver qu'ils sont
coincés dans la rue et bekaert et vous
ceux qui sont près du safa de lvt vous
s'il vous plaît sur les côtés de part et
d'autre afin de permettre à ceux qui
arrivent et peut être bloquée de ne pas
être coincé dans la rue est une fois de
plus nous sommes débordés par notre
succès nous avons avec tous à d'autres
artistes investissent hien vous le
connaissez ils savent pas il s'agit de
sylvain roussel de location du patriote
violence et le collectif transphobia je
voudrais applaudir signer en selle
bonjour à tous ce musicien professionnel
dont essentiel est suspendu
mes collègues à l'artiste ont largement
eu le tort de dénoncer
les artistes du showbiz donc je ne
resterai pas ses propos c'est le moment
de vous présenter ce projet
d'association france fait bien
ses projets qu'ils encourent et de
préparation depuis plusieurs mois et qui
réunit un frein dans nombre de secteurs
culturels et de département nous avons
même des personnes à la réunion
notre objectif est de défendre une
culture francophone livre est accessible
à tous
nos missions seront donc les suivantes
rompre l isolement et donner la parole à
tous ceux qui résistent face au rouleau
compresseur communiste mettre en
relation des professionnels résistants
entre eux met en relation des élèves
avec des professeurs avec les mêmes
valeurs
il faut penser à nos jeunes et la
transmission
mais être aussi l'outil culturel
camardes de résistance pour les autres
corporations
c'est aujourd'hui l'union sacrée
enfin et surtout favoriser les actions
libre tant de métier avec la
privatisation des lieux notamment vous
pouvez tous de venir donc hector en
prêtant au salon en devenant mécènes en
fait ce projet culturel faut donc
reprendre la main sur notre ce temps est
arrêté doit-on d'autorisation de ceux
qui nous mettre sous tutelle
vous pouvez nous retrouver sur les
réseaux sociaux nous avons une chaîne
youtube des réseaux dits sociaux mais il
ne faut pas oublier la vie réelle
[Applaudissements]
vive la culture française vive la
culture venir vive la france vive
pour les contacts vous pourrez me
retrouver sur la nouvelle culture
ici présentes bravo bravo à cilaos elle
revoit tous les artistes qui se verra
comme
d'une avons un message enregistré par
quelqu'un
que vous connaissez
il s'agit de la directrice de l'isepp
elle a répondu à l'appel et hillion
sacré en vidéo aujourd'hui ce 8 janvier
2022 il s'agit de marion maréchal le
magazine ou à la vérification de ce jour
mais je le soutiens avec ferveur la
démarche de florange et hip hop de tous
ceux qui sont très heureux aujourd'hui
tu crois qu'il est absolument important
de se mobiliser et d'être ensemble pour
lutter contre la dérive terrible à
laquelle nous assistons à la fois dans
les parents les dracks du président de
la république qui nous fait courir tels
des canards sans texte derrière des
réglementations de plus en plus à sion
dont la pertinence l'efficacité elle
n'est jamais vraiment mesuré qui nous
impose une société de la défiance du
traçage du contrôle de la suspicion qui
n'est pas le modèle de société des
grandes démocraties quelques imaginons
une société dans laquelle chaque citoyen
va regarder l'autre avec défiance
équivalent heureusement met à mal
l'unité de la nation une société où la
liberté
n'existe plus et que nous sommes sous la
menace permanente et bien de
restrictions sur les droits et libertés
fondamentales que dirt pourtant protégé
le conseil d'état et le conseil
constitutionnel
c'est pourquoi je vous invite à
continuer le combat à être nombreux à
vous mobiliser vacciner ou non
d'ailleurs pour défendre ce modèle de
liberté ce modèle français et je le dis
perdre devant permettre que nous
mettions fin à cette fois
merci merci à lorient maréchal davout
répondu à cet appel de l'union sacrée
nous avons à d'autres représentants du
camp souverainiste du camp de la liberté
parmi nous il est président du cercle
crystals il a été de presque toutes les
manifestations il n'a cessé de se battre
aux côtés de nous tous pour de liberté
il s'agit de pierre-yves rougeyron
mika mode bonjour chers emmerder merci
d'être là
emmanuel matheron notre vivant leader
grand dealer de haines et de peurs a été
notre attaché de presse aujourd'hui et
nous a réunis merci à lui
[Applaudissements]
mes amis rené char le grand poète la
résistance disait agir en primitif
penser en stratège agir en primitif
c'est ne pas se poser de questions sur
l'essentiel ils ne toucheront pas nos
enfants
mes pensées en stratège c'est ne pas
être du de maquereaux n'oubliez pas
qu'avec lui il elle est terrifiée il a
les hallucinés il à ceux qui ont peur et
qui ont besoin de leur dose leur dose de
mépris à votre égard et qu il veut les
préserver de l' influence de pécresse la
macro jupons qui vous attendra au
tournant dans quelques mois pourrait
être le nouveau visage de l'ordre euros
pharmaceutique méfiez-vous des messieurs
ne
[Applaudissements]
merci à pierre hémon géant merci pour ce
discours et merci pour tout ce que tu
fais depuis le début de notre lutte nous
avons un message d'un invité surprise
qui nous envoie un message de soutien à
la résistance française
il est il habite il est américain il vit
aux états unis d'amérique il est
l'ancien directeur de campagne de m il
s'agit de steven
[Applaudissements]
lumbala
oui si marrant ce conseil est des vieux
nice
ira jouer et
didier dulac bail de viol un grand club
et point qu'il est et ce qui est
à vous est pris chez georges blanc et
ivoire yj
et pour cause des
saints oui bon d'accord
le fait que le seigneur de mort we are
you back à demi mot
merci merci à steven pour ce message
pour ce soutien vous le voyez depuis le
canada depuis l'étagé dit le monde
entier je fixe et sur les ristournes
paris
[Musique]
nous avons d'autres combattants de la
liberté un défenseur ardent de la
souveraineté de la france du droit des
français a décidé problème il est
président de génération frais site il
s'agit de sonorités loi
[Applaudissements]
merci ou évidemment parlera du fait qu
site bonjour à tous merci d'être venus
aussi nombreux
normalement dans un monde normal si on
peut appeler ça comme ça en régime
démocratique on convint et aux régimes
autoritaires ont contraint et emmanuel
macron la france d'éveil au maquereau le
régime emmanuel macron est assurément un
régime autoritaire non seulement ils
cherchent à contrôler les français et en
plus vous l'avez vu il a dit il a envie
d'en merdé raynaud alcine est non
seulement ça régimes autoritaires mais
on a la tête de l'état un personnage qui
semble jouir
d'emmerder les non vaccinés mais
d'emmerder les français puisque ce n'est
pas une histoire de vacciner mon
accident macro emmerde tous les français
sont pas qu'ils soient syndiqués aime
tant d'accidents en mer de tous les
forces et qu'ils soient vaccinées ou non
macro emmerdes l'ensemble des français
maquereau en mer de l'est font c'est
aussi il faut le dire de manière
permanente parce qu'il n'est pas ça ils
emmerdent les français quand ils
continuent de fermer des lits do
[Applaudissements]
depuis 2007 emmanuel macron et son
gouvernement ont fermé près de 18000 le
lido pitot aient finalement puisque vous
le savez l'union européenne demande
chaque année de réduire les dépenses de
santé et de qu'on ferme des lits
d'hôpitaux mais le pire dans tout ça
qu'on peut regarder les chiffres la
dernière année disponible l'année 2020
année qu'ovide c'est celle où la ferme
et le plus de lits d'hôpitaux
avant de vouloir l' emmerder conseil il
emmerde évidemment les soignants la suit
quand on cerne cinq mille cinq cents
lits d'hôpitaux aux pleine crise du co
lead le criminel ce n'est pas le maxi
mais le feeling et c'est emmanuel macron
[Applaudissements]
2 puis
hahaha
cette histoire de passes lexine elle est
d'autant plus absurde qu'on le sait le
vaccin est une protection individuelle
il n'empêche pas les transmissions et
donc ça doit rester un choix individuel
emmanuel macron en r&d français
puisqu'il veut faire du chiffre avec sa
politique avec son pass vaccinale des
douze ans demain peut-être des cinq ans
plus tôt d'avoir une solution de bon
sens et de cibler les populations à
risque en fait ce que veut faire le menu
mac rousse est emmerdé ont cessé
d'utiliser les français c'est de montrer
et bouc émissaire c'est tellement plus
simple accuser les non vaccinés
le flexi début de mon intervention il le
fait aussi quand il affiche le torchon
l'union européenne sous l'arc de
triomphe et divise les français
ce drapeau où il était dans le seul
texte souhaité ne laissera posséder au
référendum de 2005 le tc eux les
français avaient rejeté à 55% et maltais
se vanter mais le maquereau nous remet
ce drapeau il le met sous l'arc de
triomphe au dessus de la tombe du soldat
inconnu
c'est un véritable scandale il crache
serait tombe du soldat inconnu il crache
sur les 55% qui avaient voté non et gras
chaud l'ensemble des français quand il
dit qu'il ou s'emmerde donc je vous
invite ne vous y trompez pas
il y à des élections en 2022 je vous
invite tous à faire barrage à emmanuel
macron merci à vous
vive la liberté
vive le flexi et vive la france libre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci merci à challans et gallois pour
son message et pour son combat nous
avons parmi nous quelqu'un qui
représente les employés du secteur
aérien il est personnel navigant dans
l'aviation civile
vous avez peut-être déjà volé avec lui
il s'agit de dieu de pour écouter son
témoignage
est à venir
[Musique]
bonjour la france désormais rld et
bonjour les pâtes les patriotes
je suis porte parole d'un collectif qui
s'appelle les navigants libre avant de
porter leur parole je vais m'exprimer en
tant que citoyen jusqu'à 20 secondes
pour remercier les patriotes et florian
philippot de toutes les manifestations
qu'il organisait depuis un an même plus
qu'un an parce que j'estime que ont été
traités comme des chiens les dernières
avec le mas partout que c'était un comme
vous savez dans ces manifestations n'a
plus regardé rire voir s'embrasser
danser et on est redevenus des hommes
non pas des chiens
maintenant je vais porter la parole de
notre collectif
je vais frire ou donc au nom des
navigants livre qui rassemble des
pilotes et hôtesses de l'air des
stewarts de la maison civile française
notre mot d'ordre c'est la liberté de
choisir de choisir pour notre corps
le personnel navigant d'air france
d'europe et transavia
d'easyjet france de concert vers carey
tous les jours de nouveaux collègues
vacciner et non vaccinés nous rejoignent
choqué par ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
dans notre pays au même titre que les
serveurs les restaurateurs les gendarmes
les pompiers plein d'autres professions
nous sommes soumis à l'obligation de
pain sanitaires pour travailler sur
certaines missions en france et dans les
dom tom demain se passe de la honte
deviendra exclusivement vaccinale c'est
à dire qu'on pourra plus se tester pour
travailler non vaccinés à travail
[Musique]
la totalité d'entre nous sommes très
suivi en sang en santé en parfaite santé
et le bénéfice risque est clairement
négatif par rapport à ce pseudo vaccin
en outre et d'irresponsables les
responsables de quoi irresponsable
d'être prudent au sujet d'une injection
expérimental encore en elle même
conditionnelle
irresponsable leurs débats sur des
sujets aussi importants que notre santé
et la libre disposition de notre corps
quel odieux chantage
alors oui depuis le 12 juillet
le gouvernement nous a déclaré la guerre
dans leur grande mansuétude nous laisse
le choix de soumettre ou disparaître
mais nous reste in et sont devenus des
boucs émissaires pour mieux dissimuler
les véritables racines du mal la
faillite de l'hôpital public la
compétence mais le cynisme de nos
dirigeants et naspe not least l'échec du
tout à ce final alors ne nous laissons
pas abattre battons nous tous ensemble
regroupons nous dans l'union sacrée pour
une france plus juste et plus humaine
vive les forces libres vivent les
patriotes
[Applaudissements]
et si et si et guillaume et merci à tous
les camarades qui porte sur combat ô
combien utile
nous avons parmi nous à parlementaire un
parlementaire courageux qui façonnera
journée plateaux télé essaye de l'avocat
des écoliers de crainte des guerres et
les sénateurs du rassemblement national
il s'agit de ses fins de relief
[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis
c'est avec beaucoup d'honneur
et beaucoup d'humilité que je m'exprime
devant sodome
sous lequel repose le plus grand des
français qui avait fait savoir dans nos
mourir qu'il souhaitait reposer
aux côtés
de la scène au milieu du peuple français
qu'il avait tenté mais
deux cents ans plus tard qu'elle chute
vertigineuse avec ce petit chef l'elysée
qui aura démontré tout au long de son
quinquennat à quel point il est testé la
france et qu'il détestait foncé
[Applaudissements]
vous
comme vous je les entends du m'insultait
comme vous j'ai été blessé quand vous
serez entendu veut dire qu'ils allaient
m'emmerder j'ai été très agacé et puis
et puis je me suis souvenu de ce que
m'avait dit ma grand-mère de j'étais
enfant et alors que je pestais contre un
camarade qui déjà l'emmerdé elle m'avait
dit stéphane calme toi ça vaut pas la
peine de s'énerver
on n'est jamais emmerdé que par la merde
alors je sais fort
je ne sais pas comme une manuelle macro
je n'insulterai pas le chef de l'état et
il faudrait qu'ils se conduisent en chef
d'état est penché clos pendant ces corps
il aura démontré
qu'il était un chef qu'il était le
président un conseil d'administration
est pas tant la nation
je suis venu donc je suis venu dans de
marseille
marseille où les marseillais et les
provençaux étaient nombreux à manifester
aujourd'hui dans les rues de la cité
phocéenne mancelle la ville du soleil en
ce soir du soleil méditerranéen
et du soleil de la liberté du soleil de
la vérité at il du professeur au
[Applaudissements]
un professeur que je tiens j'en suis sûr
aussi en votre nom je le tiers a salué
son combat pour la liberté pour la
vérité
se tord son sport aura été de défisc et
et de soigner et milliers de marseillais
des milliers de france au prince au
crible lui aussi lui déjà a été traité
comme un pestiféré
ceux qui ne comprennent rien à rien la
médecine se sont crus obligés de
qualifié de charlatan et landi lui déjà
deux côtés je lui renouvelle roi nous
lui renouvelons notre confiance et notre
soutien merci professeur
[Applaudissements]
et puis et puis ce fut et puis ceux
suivant tour l'autre soir ce fut mon
tour autre soir sur la chaîne lci
d'être mis de côté
une marche flux pas être mis aux
couleurs a remarqué ça m'a rappelé quand
j'étais enfant et que j'étais déjà
turbulent que déjà je n'écoutais pas la
ligne officielle et que j'étais plus dit
on me mettais au fond de la trace
eh bien on s'est cru obligé madame ruth
elkrief l'assumé
[Applaudissements]
m
en estimant que puisque je n'étais pas
vacciner mais pour contester négatif je
devais être vie en coin j'avais été
informé de ce traitement indigne mais je
n'ai accepté pour que les français qui
refusent d'être vacciné il refuse
légitimement puisque c'est un gros j'ai
voulu leur faire savoir comment il
allait être traités au lendemain du vote
du sénat parce que n'en doutez pas et
sénateurs godillots à la république en
marche et les républicains se couche
mais une fois de plus
à
vous pouvez compter sur moi je serai au
sénat mardi et je vais les rares sol et
démocratiquement sans les insulter
continuez votre cambodge où s'était
terminée je vous sais motivé pour la
liberté quand il eut être festif être
joyeux à être français
[Musique]
est si vite et si vous voulez être
éviter d'être contaminé par certains
politiques qui divisent les français qui
les montent les uns contre les autres de
taux n'est pas dans ce piège mais si
vous voulez en finir avec ce virus
au mois d'avril il y à des élections je
vous demanderais loin de retenir un
critère
choisissez un candidat ou une candidate
qui se sera engagé à supprimer certaines
crises
politiques
l'ag a subi n'est cette formation
obligatoire aux roses avril fille lila
matroni à lui mettant un gros coup de
pub de france est
plutôt merci le combat continue
[Applaudissements]
bravo et stéphane ravier sénateur jeanty
rien juste pour vous dire que nicolas
dupont aignan devait intervenir il ya
des gens des représentants de d'élèves
qui sont l'âge des en remercie et vous
allez appris cette terrible nouvelle
hier la disparition la mort de chaussée
bras député vice président de tlf et
dante est naturellement des peuls a dit
nicolas qui se peint l'assemblée contre
se passe de la honte a dit il nous
sommes en deuil et nous serons avec les
militants puis fait qu'ils sont affectés
évidemment par cette triste disparition
brutale de chaussée et loire est donc
libre à dupont aignan m'a priée de bien
vouloir excuser auprès de vous il sera
là à la prochaine manifestation
il est de l'union sacrée et se bat pour
la liberté avec vous avec nous bravo à
lui
[Musique]
nous avons parmi nous quelqu'un que vous
connaissez quelqu'un qui à l'été vos
côtés durant tous ses droits deux shows
de froid de lutte acharnée
il était avocat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il s'agit de m fabrice di vizio
oh
allo
bonjour
vous rien vous êtes
village al had been a voulu ni le froid
rien
et un accent vous avez un président qui
croit qu'il peut vous aux vertes et
c'est bien mal me connaître
monsieur vacquerolles devriez venir plus
souvent aux manifestations pour voir
caler détermination qu'elle a d'autres
alors je ne peux être long mais je vais
vous dire deux choses
pendant mes amis venus du
jura au dernier jour de l'année je suis
le premier et je serai là chaque jour
avec vous durant ces longs mois de
combats qui nous attendent
je vous ai ni aux derniers jours toute
l'admiration que je vous porte est elle
n'a pas changé sinon elle a grandi en ce
premier jour de l'année
alors tout à l'heure pendant la marche
nous avons chanté ce jour de foot sur
son téléphone je rêvais d'un autre monde
à mes amis il des de rêver
cet autre monde les habiles
[Applaudissements]
et
bien sûr nous sommes construits en
raison de
la résolution de construire amour
l'ancien boss en italie et bien il vous
faut maintenant arrêter de jaude et
construire ce nouveau monde et je veux
que je vous côté je m'y engage
concrètement je m'y engage en direct et
en vérité nous allons construire une
société où l'égalité de rejoindre à la
règle nous allons construire le monde
puisque seul on ne veut plus de nous et
bien c'est mal à nous nous retrouvons
entre nous
entre nous le matin entre nous le soir
entre nous le week end douzy demande en
haut lieu de culture et nous irons dans
nos écoles
[Musique]
tout est écrit que nous avons besoin de
vous nous sur la croix où est il écrit
au moment où vous vous dites à bruce le
séparatisme et bien moi je
le séparatisme
aujourd'hui monsieur macro le peuple de
france de sécession
mais ce n'est
absolument et enfin je voulais dit tout
au long de cette année je vous le redis
le reverront dès samedi en samedi et 12
ans et propositions extrêmement
concrètes je vous ai promis bien des
choses qui se mettent en place
des véritablement laissé mon en dernier
lieu vous rendre hommage de nouveau
laissez moi en dernier lieu vous redire
toute mon admiration
les hémois vous redire combien est-ce
que venir ici mais strictement
nécessaire laissez-moi vous redire
combien vous êtes toute la fierté de ce
pays
alors pour terminer et comme chaque
samedi quand je viens je vous le redis
et divers dans le secteur soiffards et
au courage
[Applaudissements]
visite aux
jeux histoire
et l'histoire
ray disc en
résistance
liberté
pays tu es
unique et
une idée
vous aider vous avez tenu toute la
journée sous la pluie et vous êtes
encore chaud
[Applaudissements]
merci à tous ceux qui sont là depuis le
début merci à tous les organisateurs
et vers 6 à celui qui aurait dit ce
rassemblement depuis plus d' adam et qui
va prendre la parole
il s'agit
de florian thébaux
[Applaudissements]
merci de vous envoler croiser sous la
pluie résistant quoi qu'il se passe quoi
qu'il arrive vous êtes là parce que vous
êtes ig et mésestime
alain thomas kron a prononcé
sa déclaration soc aussi indigne
cordiaux rière par l'accueil le
prométhéen destin scatologique
il a cessé être chef de l'état
à l'instant oui il asséné que des
millions de français
qu'il traite
d'irresponsables comme d'autres parler
de déplorable n'était plus citoyen il
s'est disqualifié à jamais
[Musique]
quand on est celle de l'étang
on recherche l'unité et non pas la
division
un chef de l'état combat intégré gassion
il ne cherche pas l'apartheid
un chef de l'état
ne trouve pas de bouc émissaires parmi
son propre coop bilan de ses propres
responsabilités
et dieu sait que les siennes sont
lourdes
[Applaudissements]
métro qui par bien des aspects avait
déjà lourdement trahi le peuple de
france depuis quatre ans et même avant
dans ses précédentes fonctions
a commis par cette phrase le pire qu'un
chef de l'état puisse commettre contre
son peuple
en le conduisant
au port de la discorde et la zizanie et
même de la guerre civile jusqu'au sein
même certaines familles
en agissant ainsi
métro s'est rendu coupable et je pèse
mes mots de haute trahison et se traite
en répondra devant l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand nous sommes sortis de cette
tyrannie
mes chers amis
nous nous serons là nous serons debout
nous sommes des français tiens et libre
lui nacre en nacre ans le fou n'a cran
les psychopathes d'un cran le ti en
véron et castex tapisseront les
poubelles de l'histoire de france
[Applaudissements]
car qu'on ne s'y trompe pas
battre on ne vise pas simplement les 5 6
millions d'adultes français nous
vacciner il faut évidemment y ajouter
les enfants
[Musique]
et qui aujourd'hui
souffrent subissent toutes les folies de
cette politique et voit le système
scolaire à s'effondrer comme jamais
auparavant
mais il a
aussi dans le collimateur tous les
autres français
car aujourd'hui le statut de vacciner et
bien précaire de plus en plus précaire
il ya quelques mois le statut de
vacciner c'était une sorte de cdd pour
six mois
puis un cdd de cinq mois
puis un cdd de 4 mois et maintenant le
statut de vacciner c'est un cdd de trois
mois jusqu'à nouvelle injection
oui qu'on ne s'y trompe pas tous
vaccinés est un futur non vaccinés tout
français est donc dans le collimateur
des folies liberticide et tyrannique de
mettront le dingue
voilà pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
c'est français nous devons jusqu'au bout
rester fermement et solidement uni dans
la résistance et dans le tournoi
[Applaudissements]
c'est d'autant plus vrai que je souhaite
attirer votre attention sur une autre
phase - commente emmanuel macron et
pourtant tout aussi dingues g essentiel
bacrot déclaré qu'être citoyen c'était
avoir des droits mais surtout des
devoirs
d'abord je ne savais pas que nous avions
rédigé la déclaration des devoirs de
l'homme et du citoyen je pensais que
nous avions réalisé la dca sont des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen
deuxièmement
[Musique]
si monsieur macron il y a plus de
devoirs que de droits
alors que avez vous démissionné
après laffaire benalla
que n'avez-vous démissionner au moment
dé gilet jaune
[Musique]
pourquoi votre ministre la santé le
sinistre vers en date a démissionné
quand il a fermé l'an dernier 5000 700
lits supplémentaires à l'hôpital
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi ferrand est votre premier
ministre castex si les deux voix
comptent plus que les droits dont ils
pas démissionner quand ils ont menti à
répétition aux français
[Musique]
il ne devait pas y avoir de place à
lithaire il ne devait durer que trois
mois il ne devait pas tenir compte de la
troisième dose il n'y aurait pas de
passe d'accès mal et c'était un mensonge
sur mensonge est sûrement sombre oui
s'il est de voir non plus que les droits
alors il fallait partir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en réalité dans le monde
sait les droits pour les seigneurs les
devoirs pour les que
voilà votre conception des choses
monsieur macro
voilà la conception des choses de vos
maîtres
voilà le nouvel ordre les gars et ils
veulent nous imposer voilà précisément
chalier contrepoids douilles au bâton
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vos maîtres sont les mêmes qui explique
que la liberté
s'inscrit dans un qr code
définit par une injection
décider tous les trois mois par le
gouvernement
ce cycle perpétuel des injections nous
ne considérons pas que c'est notre
liberté ce n'est pas monsieur macron
notre manière de voir
nous l'avons passionnés ici toute la
journée et nous leur dirons aux efforts
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent
[Musique]
nous sommes tous égaux en droits et en
dignité vous n'êtes pas au dessus de
nous nous sommes des citoyens
nous sommes des bêtes nous sommes des
êtres humains ni digne et nous voulons
votre victoire
[Applaudissements]
deuxièmement nous disons que notre
liberté totale
inconditionnel et qu'elle n'est pas
déterminée dans les cours de bourse de
father et moderna
et que si on n'a pas envie d'être
vaccinés alors on se vaccine rappaz
troisièmement nous réaffirmons que les
enfants quand je t'ai traité comme ils
sont c'est à dire des êtres humains
dignes et qui doit bénéficier d'une
instruction de qualité et que l'autre
recevoir normalement de chef de l'état
de leur assurer cette instruction car
les enfants sont sacrés et les enfants
sont l'avenir de la nation
4 en forme nous disons qu'un
gouvernement de gouverner dans la vérité
la bienveillance et la recherche
acharnée du bien commun et non pas dans
le mensonge les conflits d'intérêts la
corruption car il s'agit bien de cela et
la soumission un des lots vie privée et
des instances supranationales
comme l'union européenne qu'il faudra
bien que nous quittions le plus vite
possible
[Applaudissements]
si tu as aimé
très vite principe 13 sites
[Applaudissements]
alors
le pass vaccinale
doit être rejetée par le sénat
ou rejeté par
les députés s'ils ont encore un soupçon
d'intelligence et honnêteté et ça j'en
doute fortement
il doit être le cas échéant
censurée par le conseil constitutionnel
parce que se pincerait finale par vous
tous les principes éternels de notre
france millénaire et tous les principes
sacrés de l'humanité le combat que nous
menons est un combat éminemment français
parce qu'il est plein de panache et
c'est un combat uma parce qu'il se bat
pour la dignité le touche x ce qui nous
motive voilà ce qui nous unit voilà
votre tombe à point là où ira la
victoire
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes une fausse une force
considérable
nous sommes le peuple un france
héritier de fiers combattants de héros
de génération de résistants nous avons 2
700pts en est qui est pour nous il reste
pour sabilité
comme peuple de france nous appelons
solennellement aujourd'hui et c'est
inscrit dans notre constitution en
lettres d'or le seul souverain c'est
nous c'est le peuple savez pas vous
vous n'avez aucun droit sur nous nous
sommes votre m et si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord vous souhaitez vous partez
[Applaudissements]
nous le rappellerons haut et fort
donc
plus nous serons pas débarrassés de
cette comédie tragique
tant que les soignants les pompiers les
militaires les gendarmes et médecins les
dentistes et au titien se jetant du et
tant d'autres n'ont pas été réintégrés
tant que nous n'aurons pas mis fin à
cette tyrannie
tant que nous n'aurons pas juger punis
et pas n'y a jamais de la cité des
tyrans et leurs complices
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre corps s'exprime aujourd'hui dans
l'union sacrée
bien sûr un écho encore total elle n'est
pas encore parfaite elle n'est pas à
sauver les uns et inédite
elle est stationné à les prometteuses
elle est pleine d'espoir elle est
revigorante haine et énergisantes elle
est celle qui nous donne la foi l envie
de continuer le combat alors je remercie
et félicite aussi chaleureusement que
sincèrement l'ensemble des intervenants
qui m'ont précédé qui viennent
d'horizons politiques
professionnelles culturelles
philosophiques aussi variés que divers
et c'est notre force mais ils ont et
nous avons tous un point commun je
dirais l'un d'eux on aime notre pays et
on aime la liberté et donc on se
laissera pas faire et on se battra
jusqu'au bout et vous pouvez compter sur
nous et je sais qu'on peut compter sur
vous et on vient à redon
je remercie aussi les intervenants
atteint venus depuis l'étranger
car l'union sacrée est aussi mondiale
que le combat est mondiale et que la
guerre qui nous est déclarée et mondial
oui il faut aussi l'union sacrée des
peuples libres comme l'a dit
magnifiquement le père de joe cole oui
il faut l'union sacrée des peuples
libres du monde libre et oui nous y
travaillons et oui nous le ferons et oui
le monde entier ce lieu
l'union sacrée ce n'est pas simplement
un coup ça n'est pas simplement une
manifestation le 8 janvier il faut que
ce soit maintenant solide installé
permanent je proposerai qu'un comité de
liaison permanent nous permettent de
coordonner nos actions d'emmener tous
azimuts juridique politique
culturelle populaire
médiatique tous azimuts il faut se
battre car c'est dans l'union combattit
c'est dans l'union on construit et c'est
dans l'union qu'on gagne et qu'on
l'emportent
[Applaudissements]
quand cette union il ya les
restaurateurs il ya les artistes ni
élève l'âme
il y a les sportifs il y a les étudiants
il y a les connaissances il ya les
fonctionnaires les soignants les
médecins du moins ceux qui n'ont pas
oublié leur serment d'hippocrate nous en
avons cité quelques-uns permettez moi de
remercier tous ces soignants admirable
qui n'ont pas cédé aux sirènes des
conflits d'intérêts de la corruption ils
sont dans les médias très rare mais dans
la vraie vie ils sont une majorité ne
pourront les applaudir
[Applaudissements]
à batailler dur la bataille allons les
aider parce que coville il s'agit de
nour est institué que peuple souverain
et respecté il s'agit de réinstaller
l'homme dans l'humanité il s'agit de
redonner ses lettres de noblesse à notre
france défigurée par ces fous notre
france belle notre france unie notre
france joyeuse l'autre france grande
entre france puissante notre france
indépendante notre france libre
voilà la portée nationale et universelle
de notre combat le travail se fera en
profondeur
car ils ont fait beaucoup de dégâts dans
les cerveaux comme il vous le rappeler
voir le sénateur stéphane ravier être
relégués au fond de la classe sur un
plateau télé parce qu'il n'est pas
vaccinée
je vous le dis franchement
je ne pensais pas pouvoir encore être
choqué en regardant cette télévision est
gelée était profondément je ne pensais
pas avoir ça un joueur de mon vivant
cette tequila swing car c'est une taie
que la three immonde et
internationaliste qui a fait ça
[Musique]
dès l'aube states il n'y ait pas eu
témoin nationale en dit long
sur les dégâts qu'ils ont fait dans les
esprits il nous faudra réparer les
choses notre pays est bien malade mais
c'est pas du comité les valable il est
maladie l'humanité et nous devrons
réinsuffler la
[Applaudissements]
même chose quand on voit tous ces débats
faut-il continuer de soigner les non
vaccinés
faut-il autrement dit laissé crever des
millions de français et ses chansons
fous ils sont aussi fous qu'indigne oui
le travail se fera en profondeur car ils
ont détraqué beaucoup d'esprits par la
peur et par la propagande
il faudra réparer ce qui a été détruit
retisser les liens déchiré renaître
l'amour et le change de la citoyenneté
là où la haine et la délation ont été
intronisés
passionnant noble du et notre combat
mais il en vaut la peine et j'ajouterais
nous n'avons de toute façon pas le choix
pas le choix par rapport à ceux qui nous
ont précédés et qui sont morts qui ont
donné leur vie pour notre liberté est
pas le choix pour ceux qui nous suivent
c'est à dire nos enfants et nos petits
enfants car eux ne peuvent pas se battre
oui on peut se battre pour eux
[Applaudissements]
ce combat nécessite bienveillance
intelligence force courage ténacité et
surtout une ni thé vaccinés non vaccinés
et futur non vaccinés tous unis tous
ensemble pour les libertés dans la
résistance pour la france libre
[Applaudissements]
bravo à vous ni justes et dignité
liberté
divise t
[Applaudissements]
il
liberté
il le fait
en
liberté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des choses
allons enfants de la patrie
le jour de gloire est
arrivé
contre tours de la tyrannie
les paras ressemblante m
l'étendard sanglant
télé
entendez-vous
nos campagnes mugir
ses parents se scinda
yves hier
jusque dans nos bras
égorger
et ce non pas
aux armes citoyens
[Applaudissements]
en mai
nous
marchons
qu'un sang
en poule à
selon
nous allons arriver les lumières de
l'espérance quant à la fin de chaque
manifestation
images qui font le tour du monde
là où il ya de l'espoir
la lumière là où il ya de lumière il ya
de l'espérance est de l'avenir avez-vous
nous ne lâcherons rien nous ne
laisserons pas faire nous sommes là que
vous bravo tout le monde pourra vous
bien d'eux bénéfique vous êtes héroïque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai
ni la terre
il était
[Applaudissements]
là
brière
il y a
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il pleut un peu je ne sais pas si c'est
encore beaucoup j'ai pas l'impression je
ne sais pas un peu en tout cas il faut
aussi penser à s'amuser il faut penser
être qu'est ce que c'est interdit il
faut santé parce qu'on n'a pas le droit
il convient parce qu'ils veulent pas
qu'on vive alors on va mettre les
musiques ya une piste de danse géante
qui s'annonce je viendrais même un peu
lancé avec vous allez à tout de suite
et
des militants vont passer parmi vous
nous faites lors de l'accueil les usages
des patriotes et ils ont le 15e déclare
mon école tout cela coûte très cher vous
imaginez bien et il nous a créé recours
suivre ça coûte beaucoup et il faut
faire un geste merci à vous tous provost
méfiez vous on peut dire tous les
niveaux et tous ceux qui ont travaillé
pour la réussite de cet événement très
bonne humeur en insécurité renault
vous pourrez la boutique permettant
adhésion à ces livres de flyers et voir
tout ce qu'il ya au niveau de la
distance qu'il faut près ils sont
derrière le simple de elle désire vous
est maintenant
vicious interdit physique
iv
viré son caractère et son épure que
masquer d'autres achats
[Musique]
lee
soupes et les salades
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
c'est mon jour
oh
[Musique]
la nuit
esson
il est de la france qui ravit
[Musique]
je suis
toutes les
[Musique]
m
sur vous nous
on
g tu dis
tu
m
[Musique]
là